four US senators including Intelligence
Committee Chair Richard Burr reportedly
sold stock before coronavirus fears sent
the markets plunging one congressman is
asking the Securities and Exchange
Commission to investigate Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy what do we know
well Anthony these stock sales came
about a week before the markets started
to slide as the crisis in Asia was
coming to a head and as senators started
to get daily briefings here on Capitol
Hill about the looming threat financial
filings show that Senator Richard burr
of North Carolina he's the chair of the
powerful Senate Intelligence Committee
sold roughly between 600,000 and 1.7
million dollars worth of stock in
mid-february those sales came about the
same time that Burr had written an op-ed
assuring Americans that the u.s. was
prepared to deal with a pandemic but a
few days later he gave a speech warning
that the virus could actually have major
consequences here a spokesman for burr
says that the senator disclosed the
sales before the market started sliding
a Republican senator Kelly Lafleur also
sold hundreds of thousands of dollars in
stock starting in late January she's
from Georgia it's worth noting she's one
of the richest members of the Senate
worth about a half a billion dollars
according to some reports on Twitter
Loffler said that her transactions are
made by advisers and that she wasn't
even aware of them until weeks later
Democrat Dianne Feinstein of California
Republican Jim Inhofe of Oklahoma also
sold large amounts around the same time
now there is no evidence that any of
these senators had any inside
information coronavirus was well within
the public view at that time in fact if
anything senators were complaining here
on Capitol Hill that they weren't
getting enough information about the
crisis in the briefings they were
receiving here on Capitol Hill it's all
very interesting Nancy and I think a lot
of people were very upset when they
heard this you mentioned that there
could be political ramifications but are
there legal ramifications if as what we
as what appears to have happened
happened they sold before
or what they they sold while saying one
thing publicly and doing another thing
privately well there is something called
the stock act that prohibits members of
Congress from profiting off of
information that they glean as part of
their jobs but at this point it'd be
pretty difficult to prove that they had
inside information
when coronavirus was something that
everyone was talking about though all
right Nancy thank you very much